motive bei ikea einkaufen und das
bedeutet in meiner wohnung gibt es jetzt
deutlich mehr duftkerzen und wir machen
einen test allerdings wieder einmal
waren und bekommt zu einem neuen test
des video heute geht es um ikea an
lebensmittel denn jedes mal wenn ich im
ikea einkaufen gehen oder wie kann jetzt
sagen würde der ikea dann bin ich danach
schon im man so erschöpft ist wenn ich
zu diesen ganzen lebensmittelbereich
komme schon gar kein bock mehr hat mich
darum zu schauen aber ich habe jedes mal
gesehen und mensch da gibt es ja doch
einiges an sachen einfach so essen
trinken lachskaviar passte da habe ich
mich heute ins auto gesetzt und habe
gesagt ich fahre zu ikea ist trade an
den beko sachen vorbei auch wenn es weh
tut und besorgt wir mal alles an
lebensmitteln was ich da so findet war
sehr happy
die haben jetzt einen vegetarischen hot
dog dieses videos übrigens nicht von
diekirch gesponserte die haben gar keine
ahnung dass ich das hier mache war ich
ja fast noch mit mir zusammenarbeiten
möchtest dann schauen wir doch mal in
unserem rückblick hälfte und schaden als
wir denn hier so tolle drin haben ich
glaube die fangen an mit einer sache ich
habe gesehen dass es solche
trinkpäckchen mit pressebank geschmack
jetzt so gibt kann auch ganz ehrlich
sein dass die produkte schon seit jahren
leer stehen und die so nie gesehen hat
okay japan nie so drauf geachtet so hhk
die kia gönnt einfach ein papierstau
impressed ich meine diesen preis gibt es
als marmelade als sirup ich hatte schon
mal diesen sirup neu mit dass jetzt
nicht sein aber interessant ich muss
sagen ich finde es extrem lecker jetzt
haben wir die drogen gibt wollen
natürlich auch was sie essen kam mit was
sein ziel im an
kartoffelchips mit eingelegte pilze
geschmack ich liebe eingelegte pilze
geschmack ich habe noch niemanden pilz
chips probiert sieht aus wie so ein
kessel ikea wenn du mich jetzt bei den
chips enttäuscht wenn ich schmecke ein
bisschen mehr knoblauch als pilze aber
die sind richtig lecker das irgendwie
saukomisch diese umkehr chips ikea chips
mit dem ikea logo es gibt das seminar
süßen lebens mit der irgendwie zu
richtig ernst nehmen weil er überall hat
ikea draufsteht da ist keine milch drin
kennt ihr bei euch so ikea freaks diese
wirklich eher ob das heft sind
eigentlich müsste man solchen leuten so
eine ikea motto party schmeißen
ok ich freue mich hinter fällung
erwartet habt café im sommer so was
schwer zu essen hara kugeln überzogen
mit kakao haltiger platz und
kokosraspeln ich finde die sind wirklich
gar nicht mal so schlecht ich verstehe
noch nicht warum ich so krassen
kaffeegeschmack gemeint habe aber da
nichts erwähnt wird schäfer foto bringst
leider nicht unter dem netten irgendwie
süßigkeiten mit und schmeckt nach kaffee
werden probieren
ich möchte das café na ja ich glaube aus
dem kühlschrank sind sie noch besser als
nächstes probieren wir mal diese kekse
in schokoladengeschmack kaffee ist
memorial moment bis leichter imbiss
clips also dieser text macht mich fertig
ich hoffe ich muss jetzt nicht zu sehr
lachen
wir sind richtig baby es ist auf jeden
fall wieder die gewohnte qualität und
dann dreht man den pixo seite denkt sich
so boom sahne creme oder bordell nur
noch mal den schoko raus lässt er in
biscuits also ich bin begeistert
marmelade schoko probier's mal mit dem
mit marmelade
boah scheiße das ist echt der werbung
und ich diese kekse essen habe ich los
jetzt so meinen großeltern auf der
terrasse zu sitzen kaffee zu trinken und
ab und zu mal sich so ein keks zu nehmen
also schoko standard blecker braucht man
nicht drüber reden aber der wäre ich
heute in ganzer linie überzeugt ich hab
mal ein bisschen lust auf als
gummiartige gelantine freie des jp kelly
vorwärts flut clever weit wäre und mein
gott thor ist das wirklich weit wäre bei
frucht als 250 mal geschafft jetzt bitte
in die kommentare wisst ihr was
waldfrucht geschmack ist sind auf jeden
fall nicht vegan sonst hätten sie dass
sie ganz groß hingeschrieben ameland
viele freitag wir haben hier sehr viele
ängste waldfrucht geschmäcker und 14
früchte also wo wir mache ich den
scheiße
das sind 3 verschiedene
geschmacksrichtungen ihr könnt ja mal
erraten was die waldfrucht ist hin der
cranberry und waldfrucht also ich glaube
dass das bald er prima weil dort alter
er schmeckt original er wie eine
duftkerze mutter ja
da klebt an den schäden die sich gerade
aus sehen wie sie hin den man so ein
bisschen erdnussbutter gibt der schmeckt
einfach nach kaugummi an diesen service
können die auf jeden fall noch arbeiten
was dieses wort gabi welz herausfinden
und wasser die tiere an der
schokoladenseiten front zu bieten
natürlich die böning mischung von
schokoladen die schokolade hat das und
zertifizierte wie sieht sehr schön aus
so zum verschenken einziges halt du
verschenkt er sportlers sagte über dich
aus extrem süß aus um mein gott ich kann
mir gut vorstellen wenn man irgendwas
verpackt und packt man diese dinge da so
zu reihen blau-gold rosa und will muss
ja wieder ein tolles farbkonzept auch
die verpackung sind fantastisch das in
unsere schokolädchen par am 11 und wenn
gott hergestellt in spanien klar die
spanier sind ja bekannt für ihre gute
schokolade also das hat natürlich jetzt
hier keine lind qualität aber käufer auf
jeden fall nicht schlecht was haben wir
hier blau das ist man doch ich liebe süß
und salzig es ist die beste kombination
die jemals erfunden wurden silber als
bestimmten ins bonbon mense ich verstehe
warum in chocolate in den usa so groß
ist bei uns ist das so rentner
schokolade budget letzter arsenault
teller an den seiten hatte man gesehen
was wohl gefühlt also außer dass
schokolade und münzen verbrechen an die
menschheit ist nicht die lecker jetzt
gibts die gleichen chips noch mal mit
seil tägliches leben und dazu habe ich
alkohol gefunden
hier wird allseits beliebte öl news
lager von ikea hergestellt den späten
schrank bier und appleinsider
so sind die chips auf wollen wir mal
gucken wie sich sieht man auch volk das
ist der salz und das ist der mit maske
und der sonst schmeckt richtig nach
altes fett ich bin überrascht also wenn
ihr euch die chips bei ikea holen wollen
oder lieber liegen war schluss und
lichtdesign ziehen her bier
[Musik]
ich frage mich an dieser stelle halten
würde sich gm wir kaufen kannst du
jemanden hin und stellte dir so ein ikea
wir darauf dass kaltes könnte man doch
in keiner welt noch unkommentiert lassen
sonst kriegst ist jetzt so danke micha
und dann hast du so ein ikea bier in der
hand
einfach weil es lecker also schmeckt auf
jeden fall nicht schlecht an gamal zum
nächsten
was ein bisschen aussieht wie diese 55
ich finde das sehr schlicht aus und
könne das allein macht 0,1 prozent also
fast nichts an alkohol mensch zu süß zu
wenig sauer zu wenig alkohol
dann können ja auch apfelschorle trinken
er trinke ich doch lieber meinen
preiselbeer sierung mich noch ein schön
nachtisch leute ich habe noch soviel da
grüne erian in sachen schon noch mal
probieren wollte das stinkt nach alkohol
manager aus
das können auch die mandeln sein lassen
es probieren
also die konsistenz ist als ob sie ein
paar canucks regale in den mixer
geschmissen hätten bloss noch so ein
bisschen holz sägespäne von diesem
pressspanplatten da fische gesehen hast
dann kommt ihr eine alkoholfahne
entgegen
georg ihr habt nicht so enttäuscht ich
hatte so eine hoffnungen dinge hat mir
bis hier vorgestellt vielleicht mit
creme bizkit drin weil zum sind besuchen
oder was fruchtiges jetzt will ich
irgendwann um mir die laune wieder hoch
hebt kommen wir zu unserem letzten
produkt cakes bizkit betritt ist geil
damit kann man dank beschreiben wie
abonniert meinen kanal kommen sie an
live nix dran nein aber sie sind auf
jeden fall stabil wie mal wenn ich merke
als ob da gar nicht so viel zucker
werden doch da ist sogar sehr sogar
die schmecken echt schon gesund aber das
liegt daran weil das walzen vollkorn ist
wie besucht mich doch auftritt und das
war der große kia snackt es ich hoffe
das hat dir gefallen beim zuschauen und
vielleicht möchtest du meinen kanal
abonnieren falls dies noch nicht getan
hast schreibt mir auf jeden fall in die
kommentare was sind eure lieblings next
bei ikea was müsst ihr immer mitnehmen
was ist so ein geheimtipp sagt er
vanessa als nächste wahl des schiffs
gelenken und wir sind uns das beim
nächsten mal wieder
eure ikea warnen